claiming that Grand Champion prize of
that trophy you can see it right there
on the left-hand side of the screen so
there we go Korea vs. Korea here winner
gets to go to the grand finals against
Japan's Chickering this is gonna be
awesome and you know throughout the year
we've talked so much about the regional
diversity in tech in Pakistan USA EU
Peru South America chapter Paul Phoenix
now coming up for me but look at the top
three we have Japan and Korea once again
I look man nobody said this is a
Japanese game he is out of the
tournament - an American player but
still Korea Japan steel standing strong
in his losers final but guys one more
time if you want me to take it make some
noise what about fate old side will be
playing amazing you guys want him to
take it yeah yeah he's getting a little
more support out there I like that Wow
the tiger knee let's go the Phoenix me
all - the punishment rolls around you
kick quick sidewalk right there
nice feel ready enough to get the block
this is a first two three ladies and
gentlemen the back one to either get
that first round I'm gonna go to me beat
pressure out of old saw now and that's
what he likes to do like you feel like
Robert you drink cuz it'll be - in your
face because now for one you're gonna
hit you if you get too loosey-goosey
with the movement out there looks like
there's me a balcony break he doesn't
get it full circle in this round doesn't
even have rayjet lightly beside at me
he's fishing hard for that magic for
right now they've already burns their
blue death fist get off of me
hands off the high tide Oh wake on the
troll bars just about even out I'm
beginning to get the plenty of time
still to close it out here 17 on the
clock and as a death is worth a damage
right there broke but the stands your
kick is gonna close it out for ol Sun
one round of peace and his losses final
eight Wow hold me attack twice in a row
that that holds on three in a row let's
go want to go zip it down back to on top
of it but look at that wall man old son
you off the wall don't matter what what
kazuma running to bunch of magic for
don't hit a pun we said he's been
fishing born finally finds his mark
pulls a rabbit out of his hat or the
tiger I should say two rounds climbing
high ground above here comes me they'll
walk Harry's gonna be easy here
bing-bang-boom
that three two backs away two all Fang
look at this pressure could be finally
getting hit with a wild span Oh Oh big
damage and the wall on top of a wall
carry down to she look at the damage and
the downtown is blue all Sonia stop
what a comeback there old saw get in the
first game here in our losers final and
look at the crowd you guys like in this
second hell here you are doubles like no
I'm not but old Sun on fire right now
game one of course this is a race to
three games first to three losers final
of course you know chickering's just
wait paying attention at this point
nobody's gonna get the winner of whoever
decides to step up to the plate after
this match going back to the Mishima
dojo as well but yet man
you use those - force people like why
would you let them do that Kazumi has so
much range or moves like down for one
that magic for is another you start
trying to fast and I'll get click yeah
that's the whole thing Oh quite a circle
back for get the full combo big damage
already look at the damage here one time
I won it that's it
never gonna forgive you for that brought
up we're trying to help okay
now three and these these fool crouched
down three old sign does such a good job
because he switches from movement to
poke and you really keeps you on your
toes
running slide they're like soy diesel
right but it's got somebody waiting to
the right lines to be able mix-up quits
nice that once again look how he just
made sure he had to stay in this corner
he's still fighting to get away spins
the blue bed fists to the four four two
one
and that's such an old-school mix of red
pulse four four two one either mid mid
or mid high yeah mate I need MIT steel
cancelable though and now that's a combo
to and available to do some full crouch
come on just pull cast down for two are
now the backcourt round nice back one to
once again look at these playing super
calm with their fault other side step
fan I'm telling you right now
old son has been doing that all day
quick side step to the right and then
the move rips and then he gets the punch
and that time he had the hockey blow-dry
toes optimal way oh he had enough health
right so even those blocked the punch
wouldn't have enough to kill him would
have left him enraged you would've been
fine but now he just has a pixel we
might see a blue thing here I will get
oh we're good we're good
okay okay I want pan to get it out now
what's wet it'll rip you were freaking
out dude my chairs what
down for one that's what I was talking
about you can see I'm just walking for
it making it respect that down for one
quick sidestep rights coming from me but
that's how you get hit by that magic for
this batch of kids Wow it was my step
for running to look at the pressure
hoses like you got once I've even hit a
button cuz a punish and man this olds on
have knees number here he beat up
earlier now he's dominating here and
looking at get the forward three comp of
my feet up damage the Tigers gonna do it
the Tigers gonna do it all the wallet
they're two games nothing nice I got
third place last year
Willie switch characters here is he
gonna stick it out with the Phoenix are
we I think hit character select he
definitely hit well you want to see look
man I'm not complaining but it would
have been cool it was cool but here we
go the Steve Fox coming out for me
and he looked a little lost after
already looked kind of shook his head
thought about it man what's happening
yeah and he made that decision kind of
quick to write and like it seems like
even before you got here like you know
what we're going straight to character
select I might have to look at my boy
Steve Fox but he has multiple characters
and I said this doing the LCQ it was an
entire year where every other top-level
Tekken player had that idea of going to
multiple characters we even see Saint
kind of hint at it when we were talking
to him he was like look man I had to let
that go I just want to make sure
whatever character I pick is the best
for the moment and I feel like he is one
of the players who's actually got that
to a point where it's controllable
right now he's be way behind you the
last step looking good if anyone's gonna
bring this back three games great it's
gonna be this legend
hotel suite after the fearless warrior
like down one there something we haven't
seen out of old so much launch his hit
ratio and that is ridiculous
yes yeah just a little short it doesn't
get a second it whoa okay interesting
choice that breaks the oneplus two
throw-weight rafter the chip on the wall
maybe not enough chip in the running to
I'm gonna close it out and then Louis on
just seems to have all the answers right
now so many people are like we've been
saying this entire weekend there's so
many players that just slipped under the
radar
mmm-hmm look at it again finding its
mark
excuse the carry to the wall on top of
it Tiger steel does decent damage bro
steel buddy and it's the old side
doesn't like to have his back to the
wall too long instantly move afford goes
back in with the town for one and look
there's low VOC choice right like
depending on the range that cuz you
can't use it down back for Kathy because
the back one like she's standing during
it so he's going to town three here
instead and it's best again me cousin
those knees knocking hit the down bow to
combo yeah that's definitely true he's
losing so much damage because of and now
he's on this last game Rahman his feed
box so even if he does manage to come
back from this last game opportunity his
last round opportunity he stuck with
speed [ __ ] for here we go it's like
where he is on the verge of going home
if you guys wanted to take you better
make sure you can hear you well here we
go the pick up again from old son this
is not looking good for knee okay hey
ring true old son is a beast right now
that's a cake nice block punished by me
steal fight can me find something song
they hate ratio just went down the movie
hit that thatch kick she's not dunking
she's not gonna avoid high attack back
one too high that counter and launcher
that's what he got or flash punch he's
still in trouble once again he's got
that round but right back into the fire
he is in trouble oh man this would be
the craziest run back Sloane just
hesitated Jin hit a jab and again so far
behind always fight for behind here
again boots on he needs more than that
Oh another one when we saw this are the
men both up try to close it out trying
to get the grand finals me we'll be
going home
ladies and gentlemen rocks dragons and
he will be eliminated from the Tekken
world towards 2019 old side won't be
going to grand finals guys make some
noise for rocks dragons new you will be
going home with third place that dude is
a legend third place last year and this
year for knee Wow I mean I said it again
and again of his top eight man the
winner for this turn is not usually who
you expected to be he was probably the
heavy favorite you just looked at the
top four with special booties on the
winter side of the bracket but going
home now at third place but that means
that our grand finals is set it's gonna
be Chickering going up against Ulsan
Japan vs. Korea for the grand finals
Tina booty finals 2019 it's gonna go
down in just a second an entire year of
traveling has come down to this right
here we've been talking about the
players all year we've talking about the
new guys on the Block Pakistan and look
what it's come to
I cannot wait to see what next year
brings but first we're going to get
through this grand finals and it's about
to be a mess